here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show okay for you Glenn what
is the legitimate level of secrecy to
which our government is entitled well
we're supposed to have a government
which is why we call them public
officials which is transparent in almost
all cases except in extremely compelling
cases of national security and we are
called private individuals because
they're supposed to know nothing about
us except in very rare circumstances
we've completely reversed that so we
know almost nothing about what the
government is doing right and they know
everything about us they can read our
emails listening to our telephone
conversations monitor and store what we
do and this has been a really radical
reversal that I think we need to reverse
back to the way yeah member all right
remember in Michael Moore's sicko he
goes to France member at the end he says
you know the difference between that
country and here is here we're afraid of
the government they're rich the reverse
government's afraid of the people and
that's the way it should yeah government
should be afraid of the free package but
no we do and you know I mean I meant
after the Boston thing and we saw the
cops and the tanks and everything I've
made quite a thing about we kind of live
in a police state and it upset a lot of
people but we kind of do the police but
even they're listening to our calls
reading our emails it didn't detect that
plot they tend to sort of create their
own plots a lot of times by trying to
lure people into plots you weren't
otherwise doing them but the real pots
they seem not to catch so it's not only
invasive but kind of ineffective I mean
I'm not blaming the policing right I'm
believing for what happened there but I
do notice that they have no trouble
breaking in people's doors when they're
like smoking pot like you can read those
stories all the time like there were
they found a guy with a pipe only took
his kids away cuz you know he had a
marijuana pipe and he was smoking you
know God we can't have that in America
so okay what will it take for the
government and the military to finally
while we ask that question don't you
watch the show why are national polls
irrelevant to the gun control debate I
guess that's for you like well I'm
national polls meaning that 90% of the
people like wanted background checks and
we didn't get it done well then I'm is
not necessarily - but let's suppose it
were for the sake of our true the 90%
figure is widely disputed really yeah
and it's not that so a bunch of polls
afterwards that showed that
it's partly because there's a there's a
difference between how much people care
and so if you ask the mother in favor of
background checks and then you tell them
what that background check would mean
you get different answers but let's
presume it were true just for the sake
of argument they're not a majority enjoy
refractive pleasure and they're
certainly not irrelevant to the national
debate that by no means irrelevant but
they do have to be set within the
American context which is that you're
dealing with a right which is enumerated
in the Constitution so for example 90%
of people wanted flag-burning but you
know they can't get that if you asked a
majority you'd have a national religion
here probably say no no we just did that
it was 33% there at 34 pages okay that's
good 34% won a national religion
yeah well that there's always that that
one third you cannot March them into the
19th century no matter how hard but
right and that's good news that it's so
low good news that it's so low it's not
a majority but but my point is if you'd
found 90 percent in that poll it
wouldn't have been irrelevant but it
would have been irrelevant to what the
American government did about it because
you have the Senate and I know I watched
you a couple of weeks ago and you know I
know your things on the Senate but the
Senate exists very deliberately to be
the state's representation so once you
filter these numbers through the Senate
through the Constitution it fills a role
in determining what the president might
make a priority and what the house
should make a priority but that's not
how American government works it's not
supposed to work like that well you know
you say that because that's what we have
now but that was not always the case the
Senate was a compromise Madison who
pretty much wrote the Constitution he
didn't want to send it he didn't think
that was a good idea that that states
would know people had the same amount of
representation as states with a lot of
people I mean California has 36 million
people we get the same representation as
Wyoming which is four right but but it's
a four that was a that was a compromise
no I understand it was a cover I think
it was a good one I mean I'm happy to to
respect that you don't like it but it is
nonetheless the law of land and I think
it works very well because Wyoming and
California are very different states and
if if California wishes to change its
gun laws if New York which is to change
its gun laws that's great but they
wouldn't necessarily work in Utah right
away I mean why do it nationally why not
do it locally what do you mean they
wouldn't work well it doesn't make sense
in Utah for example where there's almost
no gun
as a tool to impose the same sort of
laws that you would need in a city like
New York well so you're saying all the
gun laws should be by state this this
kind of reminds me during the health
care debate when they when people like
who's nikki Haley was the one in South
LA says well what's what's right for
South Carolina's health laws might not
be right for New York really people
don't get gallbladder cancer in South
Carolina what sort of nonsense is that
people have the same body's the same
health issues every state that's
ridiculous Mark Bittman what with global
warming colliding with food production
around the world I'm not sure what that
means okay why are you against
genetically modified foods ie developing
crops that are drought tolerant okay
that would help out farmers and their
lives does good for questions at once
well um right the way to deal with
global warming is to reduce industrial
meat production because it's responsible
for something between 20 and 50 percent
of greenhouse yea and gas is solely GMOs
are not the answer here by any means no
and you know again Monsanto evil you
know if in that way for a long time I
know and we're talking 40 or 50 years of
evilness yes and Obama a big
disappointment on confronting Monsanto
well yes but um yeah I mean what what do
I know he's got a lot on it I had food
and GMOs and and labeling and all that
stuff what they say in and what's
happened as there's been a huge
differential and and between what they
say and what needs to happen is even in
bigger differential but but this goes
for many things okay Zachary is
prosecution the best way to address
social media bullying uh
[Music]
no probably not I mean I prosecution for
people who've committed crimes make
sense to me and bullying is a whole
separate issue and Technology is a whole
separate issue on top of that in social
media and interconnectivity in this
world that we live in which is
supposedly so much more mediate and we
all have so much more access to each
other and we're so much more intertwined
but the reality is we've never been more
fractured and you know the way to stop
bullying in any form is to connect with
your children and teach them how to be
responsible respectful contributors to
society and hold them accountable for
that okay thank you everybody Thank You
audience real time with bill maher
Friday night at 10 past bill and his
guests to her questions right after the
show at hbo.com
[Applause]